let's talk about something weird here
and something uncomfortable here but
something that needs to be addressed
because it's been all over tv
cuties with netflix okay cuties with
netflix new movie that came out
um if you've seen this movie kai if you
want to put up the poster with netflix
the the two that we have
the original poster is that one on the
right this one
and netflix oh this is the original
that's the original one what does
netflix make it this
also the original is this shows that
shots makes this yeah
so netflix goes with the provocative one
but this is the one that the original
one
uh movie that came out did well in the
sundance it did very well and then it
comes to netflix and here's what happens
the trailer has nearly 12 million views
okay by the way if you can change the
picture i don't want it to stay for too
long the trailer has 12 million views
it has 47 000 likes
2 million dislikes let me say this one
more time
the trailer has 12 million views go to
the trailer on youtube just to see the
stats as the most
latest updated stats cuties
so the trailer has uh uh you were right
yeah cuties uh
uh oh there it is okay so what number is
it okay 12.1 million views
it's got 48 000 likes 1.9 million
dislikes by the way
even that song that that girl sang
remember a few years ago that girl had
that one song
hey friday and they say it's the worst
song in the history of songs
and poor girl got so many dislikes it
was the most hated video of the year on
youtube do you remember that song of
course
the samurai sam works out to it no no no
no let's stay on this topic we'll come
back to friday
i know adam really wants to listen to it
okay i never heard it
yeah it's uh where's it at 1.2 million
to 3.8 million is it bad
most hated video of the year the ratio
is a lot better
she was likable though i liked her only
this girl can make people hate
friday friday the most go back to the
video go back to the video
12 million live 12 million views 47 000
likes 48 000 likes 1.9 million dislikes
and 598 700 signatures calling for
people to cancel their netflix
subscription
in light of cuties being added to its
library of kind by the way good friend
of mine jose gaiton okay he's one of our
co-founders
he sits on he's one of the field
advisory board members he cancels
netflix wow netflix lost 9 billion
dollars in france where the film was
released in theater on august 19 cuties
did not steer much controversy
the movie won a directing award for
sundance institute in february
they called to remove the film calls to
remove the film
have been amplified by supporters of a
conspiracy theory that top democrats and
celebrities are behind
a global child trafficking ring it's
currently trending number seven on
netflix
and then my film is a mirror of today's
society a mirror sometimes difficult to
look onto and accept but still so true
we can't blame our children for what we
value in our society
thoughts on the movie tom zenner as a
parent yep okay has a parent with an 11
year old
boy but not girl these kids are 11.
i have a 14 year old daughter i think
any movie that sexually
uh exploits children in any way is bad
is evil
i will say this i wasn't offended by
this as much as i thought i would be we
talked about it a lot you hear a lot of
bugs watch the movie i didn't watch the
movie yet but
i i did the trailer i watched a little
bit of the movie
i watched the interview with the
director i thought i would be appalled
i'm upset but i'm not appalled
um i think 11 the thing that really
bothers me is
i don't see that i mean i live in la i
don't see 11 year old girls my son
is 11 years old i'm around these kids i
don't see them at that age doing that i
think the director
had a unique upbringing in senegal or
wherever she was
born and raised a very very you know
muslim background her mother did not
look like she was you know supporting
her in any way so this is highly
personal telling her story
um i think a lot of those uh a lot this
is organized i think against netflix
right now now i'm a prude you know and
i'm christian
i would be the one person that would be
really sickened by this and i'm not
happy about it
i'm not as offended offended as i was i
thought i would be but
i just think the age of 11 to even like
paint that picture that these kids are
sexual at that age
is disgusting well let me ask you this
question you just brought up a good
point kai can you pull up to
see it what what is it is it a pg-13
movie is it a movie that tico could
watch
you know because we have filters on
netflix where my kids can go watch
movies that they want
is it allowed on them to watch it or is
it at least
a what do they have it as cute rotten
tomatoes 90
what does that mean i wouldn't be
surprised that rotten tomatoes gives it
5 like this movie uh 1.3
rating uh just see what it's uh is it a
tv tv or a mature audience it is a
mature audience
okay go up what does a mature audience
mean by the way like what age
i mean that means tv just type in tvma
what it means
assuming 16 plus tvma what does it mean
i think there's a space but there's okay
free dictionary
uh the tv uh uh program 17 intended to
be viewed
okay uh okay fine so they have it for
mature
under 70. so it's a movie for adults
they want parents to see it not
necessarily kids to see it
uh uh that's that's actually very good
to know that that's uh that's out there
okay
adam what are your thoughts about it
yeah obviously i don't have kids but all
my friends do
um i have a different opinion um
obviously um
it's disgusting i mean this sexualizing
11 year olds is not
anything that anyone would support is
not mainstream um
but i did a little research on this this
is the
this is it served its purpose
what do i mean by that this is a shock
jock like alex jones saying
i believe something crazy and i'm just
gonna run with it and i'm gonna serve
her
she did this for a reason i'm just gonna
read a few things this movie is supposed
to make people feel
uncomfortable it shines the light on
this
issue she says you have to watch the
movie to judge it so what
my film is a mirror of today's society a
mere sometimes difficult
to look into and accept but still true
we can't blame our children for what we
value in our society
so what's my point she made this to make
people feel uncomfortable she
made this for to us to speak about she
made this to stir
controversy yeah because if it didn't
now there's the problem
if people did not speak up about this if
people were not appalled by this
and people were like yeah it was a good
movie and didn't say [ __ ]
then we'd have a problem the fact that
so many people have a problem with it
is a good sign i mean that's a good way
of spinning it
okay to to say that i get what this
isn't me i'm not saying you i'm saying
that's a good way of spinning it to to
say i made it so people would get pissed
off about it fine okay i understand like
ann coulter writes certain books with
certain copies and
bill maher asks ann coulter do you just
write stuff to piss people off
yeah is that your business model she was
asked the same question on the view she
was one of the first people that said
bill maher asked her who's the person
that can win the presidency she says
today
donald trump everybody started laughing
she was the first
major pundit type of name that went out
there and said that
so i think it's a good spin on what she
said if that's her business model fine
that is a business model you can do
today
my concern is a little bit different of
a concern here's what my concern is
so remember earlier we talked about in
one the episodes adam you would remember
this where
in politics tom uh brought this up tom
ellsworth brought it up to me
he said 44 of democrats are going to
vote democrat you can't do nothing about
it they just go down the ballot done
right
42 percent of republicans are going to
vote down the ballot you can't do
nothing about it
four percent of libertarians and
dependents green they're gonna go down
the ballot they can't do nothing about
it that's ninety percent
we got ten percent you got ten percent
left that is the one that's going to
determine
and if it's 60 40 it's going to be a tie
it's what he was saying right okay
so there's a group of people that watch
this video and watch this movie and they
say
they're freaking disgusting this is
terrible there's some people that are
gonna watch the movie and they're gonna
say wow very educational i liked it good
perspective i took a lot of like people
in france yeah apparently
there's gonna be a group of people that
watch and are gonna say there's going to
be a group of people that are not going
to watch it i don't say there's no way
in the world i would spend my time
watching a movie like this right like me
right i would i don't watch that movie
by the way kai watch it last night for
be it
really yeah kai watch it on 1.5 to get
a perspective on it but here's the
problem
there's 10 percent of people that are
going to watch it that could potentially
influence them to be thinking about
something and let me explain to what i
mean by 10 of people that can be
influenced something
so you watch the show cops if you want
to show cops
how do you watch you show cops you watch
it and shout out to figure out what you
can do to skirt the camera no
not you when you watch your show cops
what do you say you're watching i watch
it for entertainment
yeah but if i'm a criminal you know how
i watch a show cops i'm like okay
got it like in the nfl yeah like guys
who went to prison friends of mine
who've gone to prison i have a lot of
friends that have gone to prison have
come come out
obviously i've interviewed a lot of
people that have spent a lot of time in
prison you know what they tell you
prison was a training camp to learn how
to commit other types of crimes
you go to jail you only sold weed or you
sold a couple things but i went in i
learned how to do
this master's degree this spring
training and this
as much as she may have good intentions
there's certain v like okay
think about it this way is there a
visual in your life as a kid growing up
that you wish you never had
yeah you don't need to say it but is
there a visual you had as a kid that you
wish you never had
do you have one yeah i'm not asking what
it is do you have one though yes
it could be a father slapping your mom
in the face you wish you never had that
okay it could be a sibling
getting smashed on the floor and
somebody hit them with the knee it could
be something sexual it could be
something you saw
that you wish you never saw we're never
going to talk about it as adults
we keep it in our minds that visual
messed with you the rest of your life
and you're 41 years old you wish you
never
had that i'm not 41. you're 40 years old
you're 39 about to be 40 right 39 about
to be 40. sure
there are certain visuals we're better
off not having
this is one of them the world is a
better place whether you watch us or not
we don't need to have certain visuals be
in people's minds that's the only thing
i'm saying about
making movies like well then who is the
villain is it netflix or is it the
director and i'll tell you that i i
think if i had to choose
that's art that's what artists do so i'm
not gonna blame the director
okay someone had to pay you're blaming
the distribution well i mean
if there's blame to go out and i think
the rage right now is kind of focused on
netflix
and i think if you look at the poster i
mean they sex those kids
up to a ridiculous degree that again i
have kids that age i don't see that if
that was a 14 year old it would make
more sense
but not at the age of 11.